all right Drew yeah Drew uh where are
you from originally where'd you grow up
grew up in a small suburb outside of
Rochester New York
tell me about your childhood growing up
you had both your folks yeah I had a mom
and dad for a little bit everything was
normal for a while when I was 11 and my
brother was seven my father committed
suicide
so we kind of had to go through that and
then shortly after my mom started seeing
someone again and then remarried later
on
so what do you think was behind your
dead suicide
uh not a lot of people know this I mean
people think it was related to
depression or mental illness or drugs
and it wasn't that this was like a
situational suicide which is a small
percentage of them he had cheated on my
mom and he didn't want her to find out
and he was a respected guy in the
community
and I was afraid he was going to lose
all that it's like if I can't have the
life that I'm that I want and to see my
kids every day then I don't want to live
and some people thought it was like
death before dishonor like a sense of
respect
um but most people didn't know why I
almost wanted to tell more people why
but I mean that's a lot of it is just a
mystery we'll never know but that was in
the note and how did that impact you as
a child
uh it made me a little bit I mean it
like but the rest of my childhood was
pretty normal like I had a lot of
friends and I you know I wasn't poor or
anything but
it first of all I had to accept this new
guy that my mom was seeing which took
like my whole life
and then I still had a a hunger a father
hunger which I still have to this day
man when I meet an older guy it's like
oh I want you to like be my mentor and
teach me things and
and
so like just dealing with those emotions
I guess and even though my childhood was
overall pretty happy there's still like
this sense of emotions and depression
that I had to deal with and some people
go through anger and like for a while
and really still like I loved my dad and
I was never really angry at him it's
almost like I understood it in a way
maybe because I was suicidal for so long
and probably because of what he did but
it just I just felt like a sense of like
empathy towards him and never really
held like held it against them for
whatever reason
and what kind of kid are you in high
school I was a skateboarder so I had a
good group of friends and it was
somewhat respected
I was cool with everybody you know just
like the cool skater hippie kid but also
started on like the Curious journey to
drugs and Molly and acid and mushrooms
and weed were pretty commonplace so it
wasn't anything like that was out of
line with what my peers are doing I was
in line with all of them and nothing was
an alarm but still like I'm staying up
all night doing Molly in high school and
like that's kind of like where the
Curiosity started and did that drug
Journey continue or yeah
yeah
and in what ways did that did that
happen
um
I mean I finished high school and in
college I I was normal for a little bit
and then I decided to isolate more and
you know I was I just started
I was careful so and I kept my grades up
and I was smart enough to know like I
didn't I was very careful to not get
addicted to something and then not take
the same thing every day but I would
take different things
every day pretty much like I became
addicted to the sense of not being sober
so I already in college now I'm trying
cough syrup I'm trying different pills
and random pills that I'm getting from
people and drinking and having these
blackouts and pissing people off and
isolating more so that kind of whole
journey started of just dabbling in
drugs and also still maintaining a
functional life within that what did you
want to do with your self as as an adult
you're going to college I major I didn't
really know what I wanted to do I was
just kind of thrown into it yeah so I
got a kind of a General Degree in
Communications where did things go from
there
um I ended up getting like a good job at
an engineering company and
this I was still living away from home
so I didn't have too many friends
I was really excited about my job and my
career but then outside of that it's
like I just felt like life was
meaningless I didn't have many friends I
did I had hobbies and stuff but I wasn't
super excited about them
and I've been an Atheist for a while so
like these these atheistic nihilistic
almost in cell-like views like resentful
at dating in women and life doesn't have
any meaning and why try because in 100
years it won't matter like I can argue
myself and make a convincing point that
nothing matters so why try it all you
can do this the opposite like nothing
matters and you might as well do the
best you can but I made a compelling
argument in my head just for negativity
and as I'm living by myself in Buffalo
that's kind of when I started like it's
like I'm bored like I if I can't get a
girlfriend then I'm just gonna
self-destruct and I'm hanging out with a
lot of transgender girls like this was
because now I'm living by myself and I
had been curious about this for the
longest time
so now I'm starting to seek that out on
Craigslist back then and then Grindr and
it's like trying to fill the void of a
relationship with as much random sex as
I could
like and it made sense at the time it
still kind of does when I talk to guys
and they're like I can't have a
girlfriend so I'm going to self-destruct
I get it man but you don't have to like
go that way dude and so I'm seeing a lot
of these trans girls and then I'm
picking girls up off the street that's
like hey you want forty dollars you want
to hang out
and I didn't want to just [__] right
like I wanted to like feel like we're
dating for the next three or four hours
I want this to be an experience like
let's hang out and watch TV and smoke
and [__] and fall asleep together and
get breakfast and like if we say I love
you to each other too even like
for this like taboo like excitement then
like even better so I wanted that whole
experience from people and then I met
one and she was smoking crack
and I was like am I gonna get an
addicted she's like no people bounce
back I was like all right so I smoked
crack with it all night
and
then I went back to my job at the
engineering company right and but then
the next Friday would come and you'd
drink a few beers and you're bored and
you have nothing going on the whole
weekend and it's like I might as well go
do this again
so like that continued happening and now
now I'm at the point where like it as
soon as I did that drinking was forever
changed because now every time I drink
I'm gonna think about smoking crack
and then I end up smoking crack not only
with people on the street but also
people that I really respected other
business people other mentors other
people in my building that just happened
to have some on them that day like it
was surprising to me the amount of like
really capable smart business people
that I'm smoking crack with now
and not all the time but you know
weekends and once in a while it would
come up and it was something that I
couldn't even though it wasn't a
physical addiction like there's a
spiritual malady there
that's wrong with me and like this a
mental Obsession I guess in a way for
adventure and excitement that I'm
seeking out like I want to Adventure
through drugs and through sex and like
just fill the void with as much outside
influence that I can
um how many relationships would you get
into like that
oh tons
man
whoever I mean it got to the point where
it didn't matter
and it got to the point where it'd be
guys
and got to the point would be grinder
that's the point where you eat bath
houses
really disgusting dude but it's just
like
I just want someone to love on me I
don't care would you call yourself a sex
addict or
um I don't really like that word addict
but I'd say sex habit yeah yeah be more
of a crack addict that just you know
because crack addicts will have
heightened yeah I don't think I was a
crack at it because I didn't do it all
the time but when I did it and go nuts I
mean I was just an impulsive decision
maker you know
um like it's it didn't really matter
like what what the substance was like
they're all symptoms for the spiritual
malady and like that's that's what was
going on right then so even at this
point though I'm still not physically
addicted to anything
then I tried Kratom which is a legal
supplement you get at head shops it's
similar to an opiate but it's not and
you know it's like alcohol like if you
can do it in moderation like cool and it
should be legal but for me I started
doing it every day and I developed an
addiction
and I was like I'm different because I'm
taking Kratom to help me make money so
now it's Justified I'm thinking Adderall
to help me make money and at first it
worked really well and I was like this
is my secret to success like this is why
I'm successful it's gonna be taking this
drug I'm like Limitless
and after like nine months like now it's
like I need it and I can't function
without it I'm having hair loss and
you're constipated for days and I'm
drinking a laxative every morning before
I take Kratom and then taking Kratom all
day
and
plus the sex plus the crack and
everything else right so
that was like kind of the worst that it
had got
um I had also you know I had experiences
of getting beat up by a couple different
trans girls one gave me bad bugs one
gave me gonorrhea so I had all these
different things happen
and that's kind of when I figured I
should try going to recovery
and the first time I went man like I'm
an atheist and you start seeing God and
I was like I'm not doing it
so then I go back you know I smoke a
blunt like two weeks later and then like
another week or two everything just
Falls right back in like it's a
progressive illness so you pick up where
you left off it stays the same or gets
worse probably gets worse and
did that for another year
and then tried going to recovery again
for like two weeks
same thing happened like I'm not going
to believe in God like shut the [__] up
and I was like an angry atheist you know
like a nihilist within cell views you
know you can be an angry vegan you can
be a closet vegan you can just be a cool
one and I was not like a cool atheist
person I was like [__] whatever you
believe like I was watching the going
down the YouTube Rabbit Trail
and being negative with it man
and that was like it's really all in the
mindset
you know
and then the end of that chapter is when
I got HIV
and then
I just knew like something needed to
change I couldn't keep living like this
because I was like how many more bad
things are gonna happen and
I was devastated for a while but what's
the first thing I did you know well
cried for like a day called a few
friends and then you go on YouTube
you go on YouTube so you can see other
people's stories and how they do it you
see other people like me and it's like
these are normal people and they are
living with HIV and
like
I can't believe they put themselves out
there like that
some of them got it innocently through a
relationship you know I didn't get it as
like a victim I mean you can say that
but I'm accountable for this
and I held accountability to myself like
don't feel bad for me I I once you have
once you do these patterns long enough
it catches up to you and I accept that
man
and now I'm at the point where like that
started the recovery journey and I
stayed there and I went to recovery and
I said I'm not going to be an angry
atheist I'm just going to shut up and
listen and
make this a spiritual program and make
my own interpretation of what God can
mean to me through action and through
service and through experience
and that's been working and now it's
like
man this is I mean I don't believe
anything happens for a reason
when I'm here sharing a story now and
like things are falling falling in place
where now I get to help other people and
share this experience and use it to my
advantage
and that's just so powerful that now I
feel like I have a purpose and something
that I can share with other people
what advice would you give to somebody
who's kind of was lost in the
in the direct you know you were like
directionless you were just kind of
looking for love and looking for
probably all the wrong places
I don't know it's really about loving
yourself isn't it it's about loving
yourself and you know I'm I'm confident
now
like I have this purpose I have to I
have that more I mean I always had like
direction right but
you don't get it through money and
through a job you get it like through
yourself I can be proud of myself now I
wasn't really like that before I just
didn't really want to exist
I don't know if with other people I mean
you gotta it's connecting with others
that's really helped me and just having
more of an open mind and letting go of
like the anger like putting your
resentments down and Shining a light on
them and making yourself aware of them
and working through them
and they're no longer like a barrier
they can become like an asset like all
of your liabilities can also be assets
what do you think you were so angry
about
being fatherless is number one
um I was really angry at dating
like I I didn't like the idea of chasing
after girls and like pulling teeth to
get an answer and like I wish you would
just come talk to me I don't want to
have to talk to you the whole thing just
made me nervous it still kind of does
and I get HIV and now guess what now
it's even more complicated because now
there's could be a girl that wanted to
have sex with me the other day and then
you tell her something like that and it
blows her mind that's the thing about
HIV no one knows what it is people don't
know that it came from the gay community
in the 80s the whole government thing
that people are living with it like now
and that it's not a death sentence
you take a pill every day and you're
cool the only problem is the mental
stigma around it
um
so I mean like that's kind of the
hardest part but I'm
I mean you got depressed after you found
out
yeah
yeah because I just knew my life had
changed and now I'd have to tell people
this and like I already hated dating to
begin with so now it's going to be even
more complicated but instead of like
sitting here and being like I'm not
going to be happy until I get a
girlfriend
like that's I look at that like my
definition of waste of time has changed
so drastically in
I'd say things are a waste of time
before but then go on grinder for four
hours like that so that definition is
always changing like now I think it is a
waste of time if I'm spending so much
energy on dating and like wanting for
the future because I'm not being present
like wanting and like oh I'll be happy
once I get a girlfriend all right well
what about if the Habit takes two years
you're just gonna be pissed off
so I'm
trying to just chill and be more present
now and focus on the now and what
everything that's going right and
maybe it's not in my cards man to have a
relationship this second but I have the
ability to help other people in other
ways you know my
some people like marriage and kids is
your meaning like my meaning can be
recovery and sharing this message with
other people
and that's been just the fire that's
keeping me going lately how many years
has it been since you were diagnosed
positive six months oh it's fairly
recent and I got I've been in recovery
for five months have you so you haven't
used I haven't done anything oh good for
you I go to meetings you know I run the
[__] like a business
so I'm just fully in it
for you
um
yeah I mean the other thing I didn't
mention too was like in that whole
college area of the isolation was I
actually got a vasectomy as well
I think kind of from what my father had
done I just wasn't comfortable putting
kids into this world with the chance
that they would first of all have
anything like me and like be depressed
or be an addict or question why I
brought them into existence like for my
own meaning and it was like a funny
thing man like let me just worry about
like the people that are already here
but I think that that I mean that
certainly was unique to do that at like
22 and
I don't know if I would have done it
again but I
felt sure I mean I had thought about
that for a while and just didn't want to
put myself in that position
looking back at your life what would you
have done differently
looking back
I would have chilled on all the sexual
stuff and the drug stuff but I mean you
can't
do that
like I yeah if you could go back I would
but like who wants to go back 10 years
ago and redo it again it's like if you
could be a kid again when you do it like
most people say no
and now it's working out
so I don't really like try to have
regrets they're just things that like I
work past and work through and
and I don't really dwell on them but you
know it caused issues
but now it's
now it's an asset
that I can use and
people are wondering like why I'm making
this video that know me I'd be doing a
disservice to People by not by not
sharing this by not sharing like a story
of someone who's in recovery who's
bisexual who has HIV who's an addict
who's an atheist being an atheist in
recovery is already like a Black Sheep
Man
because that that's really hard and
that's what stopped me from going for so
long
but it's the biggest thing is to just
have an open mind and relax and like my
whole life I was just not relaxed at all
like worrying about everything
and once I just stopped worrying like
it's just gets a lot better and the
medications they have now for people
with HIV
probably keep your mood a little better
than
yeah I mean there are years ago they're
perfect like there's no side effects
there's there's nothing at all right so
my whole HIV experience was purely
mental
there's no physical anything like they
caught it early and like that was it and
then I'm you know I'm trying to play
research attorney for a little bit and
figure out who did it and try to do
oh can I do a lawsuit or something and
it's like I've got three or four
different candidates man I bet it could
be and I was never able to narrow it
down
just let it go at that point
I'm sitting here being angry about it
and what I could do and
I had to just move past it and hold
myself accountable
you're still up in Rochester yeah
yeah
we would like to be in five years what
do you see down the road
I would love to do more stuff like this
you know the more I think about it it's
like
I'd like to speak in my high school and
do a TED Talk and
my I don't know if I'm qualified for all
these things but I'd like to just share
my story more
you know I'd like to grow in business
and financially but I've been doing
those things and it's cool and I'm
really grateful but that doesn't give me
the fire that recovery does or working
with other people or sharing a message
like this this is like now this is like
purpose and meaning and it's just so
important to me so more opportunities
like this and being more involved and
things like this would really just be
everything
that's great
what's your biggest fear now
ah my biggest fear how old are you
you're 30. I'm 30.
um
I mean losing this spark that I have
some people call it a paint cloud
I don't think it's a paint Cloud because
I've been just confident in making this
daily decision every day to do life
differently
but
just getting like just too depressed and
too lonely and
just losing like that positive sense of
myself
um
I mean I could have all types of fears
with like with money and and business
and family and friends but and yeah
those like exist like the fears that
come to your mind first
but on like a day-to-day basis there's
really not too many
Andrew what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
hmm
I think empathy towards others
and that's like what I'm grateful for
like one of your guests said addiction
is the only
disease you come out better on the other
side than if you never had it
and are you better on the other side
right no no other disease like that
we're not I'm actually you're not
grateful you had it but you kind of are
in a way because like
you know you're not using but then
you're also growing as a person
spiritually you've grown more in the
last five months than having two years
so it's like man like you're like this
polished Diamond like coming out of
nowhere gratitude yeah and the Gratitude
and like
other people can't really relate to
addicts or to people with STDs and it's
like the outcast thing and I'm grateful
that I I can and that I can communicate
decently and let them give them space to
talk and just give space for people
to share like what's important to them
and in their message
you know there's certain friends and
family where I didn't have space to say
these type of things without judgment
and that's why I didn't in case you're
wondering
about other friends I did
and some friends I told it too and
they're like uh-huh and it's like did
you even hear me and they're like yeah I
did it's like I love that I love when I
tell people and there'd be like no
reaction
because it's like you're just you're
just listening in your chill you know
the lessons of empathy I think are
really
like just the biggest gift we can give
someone else
right Drew thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you appreciate it good
luck with everything from here on out
thanks thank you